yay
oh i'm gonna have to clean that up
thanks to curiosity stream and nebula
for sponsoring part of this video
today is my 30th birthday which is kind
of amazing considering that i started
making videos on this channel when i was
19. i'm not ready to be 30 yet i've
always thought when you're a kid that
someone who was 30 was a
old and b had their stuff together like
they knew what they were doing
like more than i currently do
spoiler alert if you are still 19 and
you may still think that
every adult is making it up as they go
along everyone is literally
living the phrase fake it till you make
it hello i've been blessed
in the studio by jasmine i think i
figured that by the age of 30 i'd have a
family but
i didn't quite imagine it'd be like this
i get emails and messages on discord all
the time
asking for advice on different topics to
do with studying or life
in general and so i thought this would
be a perfect opportunity
to kind of condense all the advice i
could give down into
one video and because the internet we
need a gimmick
so let's do this as 30 things i have
learned in 30 years
firstly work less to get more done
this was particularly true when i was at
uni but i found that if you actually
push yourself to the absolute limit at
all times
you surprise surprise burn out and you
get more done
overall if you just take a more
sustainable attitude towards work so
work hard yeah but
building time into your schedule for
relaxation and you know
staying sane secondly stuff won't get
done until you do it
this may seem completely trivial but i
don't know for me that's kind of a
powerful message to remind myself that
that thing that's on my to-do list it's
gonna stay there
until i do it so do it love is a
verb not a state you love someone when
you do things to help them because
you care about them it's not just a
question of sitting back and
saying oh yeah i love that person if
you're lucky enough to still have your
parents or guardians still be alive
then call them you know like once a week
you owe them
a lot and they really do appreciate it
mental health is
just as important as your physical
health and the two
are completely linked take actions to
make sure you're looking after both of
them
thin your paints two thin coats is
better than one thick coat the great bob
ross
was spot on when he said that talent
talent
is a pursued interest in other words
anything that you're willing to practice
you can do proper preparation prevents
piss
pour performance before investing in
anything
else invest in a good pair of shoes and
a good mattress
because you're going to spend two thirds
of your life on one or the other
so you may as well be comfortable nobody
will be remembered
forever instead of chasing immortality
which i think i did a lot of when i was
a kid
just make the biggest difference that
you can here and now
the privilege or misfortune of where and
to whom
you are born determines so much
of your potential in this world societal
privilege is real
and very unjust always check your units
don't be like me and buy an 18 by 24
centimeter
poster frame for your 18 by 24 inch
poster
incident if you like the poster you can
buy it at my merch store in the
description frequently review your goals
and your progress towards those goals
and be specific about
what you're trying to accomplish at any
given time praise in public
admonish in private one of my all-time
favorite quotes is that we are all
prisoners of our previous reference
points
a person isn't able to imagine something
until they know that it's
possible that it even exists should
always expand your horizons and
set new references clear communication
is
key to basically everything but
particularly
relationships nothing improves the world
more
than widespread education this one may
be specific to me
but you can't make qgpv from ertel pv
just make your own from temperature and
velocity data
seriously you'll save yourself a year
and a half of your life another
statement that might seem completely
trivial and banal but i think is
really true doing must come
before wanting to do take the time to
learn how to wash up
properly wash your glasses and things
like sieves first
put your cutlery at the bottom of the
bowl and then work through stuff in
order from least to most
dirty and you will save yourself so much
time you don't need to keep
that tupperware you have enough put it
in the recycling
the soul needs music like the body needs
food make time for both consume widely
and
find your tastes i will never be as good
as other people
at doing things but i don't need to be
better than them
i just need to be better than i used to
be don't watch
yesterday it is a terrible terrible
movie that wasted its potential
yes i am still angry about this it's so
bad just because someone is older than
you that doesn't mean that they know
better than you adults are just really
good
at looking like they know what they're
doing trust the data
but verify the source listen to more
david bowie
somebody on patreon told me that people
need more davey bow in their lives
and i took their advice and my life's
been better
identify how you're spending time on
your phone and remove apps that are
just a time and energy sync one of the
best things i ever did was removing
twitter
reddit and youtube studio from my phone
i feel so much more free
if in doubt just ask yourself what would
captain picard do
and lastly support the things you love
one of my favorite youtube channels is
david bull who makes high quality
japanese wood block prints in
traditional method
i really love his videos so i bought one
of his prints it's one of my favorite
possessions the astartes mini series is
one of the greatest things i've ever
seen as soon as i watched it i went to
patreon and pledged money to help
the creator make more episodes creative
industries rely on people
saying i really like this thing and i
want there to be more of it in the world
and the way that you help there be more
of it in the world
is by supporting that artist if you like
if you value online educational video
then the best way you can support it is
by signing up to
nebula nebula is a streaming service
that is run by a coalition of a huge
number of educational
youtubers there's a load of them on the
screen this is a platform that we have
total control over so
there are no ads whatsoever there's no
algorithm which means that there's
no fancy suppression of particular
topics by the website because here's the
thing about youtube
it encourages creators to play it safe
because the algorithm can suppress or
lift up videos
you are encouraged to stay in your lane
and keep making the same kind of content
on nebula creators are so free to
experiment and make new and better kinds
of
content by signing up to nebula you not
only get access to videos earlier than
on youtube but you also directly support
the work of educators
like me and other people like tiazu
legal eagle lindsay ellis but not just
that because at the moment we have a
limited time deal
working with curiosity streams so
curiosity stream is kind of the other
end of the educational
spectrum online while nebula is about
individual creators making individual
projects
curiosity stream is about the highest
production value the best
documentary series on the internet so on
the one hand
you have people like 12 tone and draw
curiosity and on the other hand you have
people like david attenborough and chris
hadfield
at the moment if you sign up for
curiosity stream you get nebula thrown
in and you get more than 25
off that's right 26 off that works out
at less than 15
for an entire year of access to the best
documentaries online
and the section of youtube that you
already watch but with no ads
early access and extra content so go
down there to the link in the
description
sign up for curiosity stream and get
nebula thrown in for 26
off and support online educational video
your support
via nebula makes such a difference in
making all of this possible
and making future content even better
thank you so much for watching
the video it took 30 years to make and i
hope that there was at least some
value to it let me know in the comments
how old you are and what the best piece
of advice is that you could give to
someone based on all of your years of
experience and that could be you being
10 or being
100. i'm really interested to hear what
you guys have to say i hope that you
enjoy the video here are some
suggestions of stuff to watch next
and that just leads me to say thanks
i'll see in the next one oh my god i'm
30.